très moqueur ce mathieu mais il a un
gros ego à rigaud le problème c'est que
cette année il a trouvé un sérieux
concurrent avec maxime gainey ah oui qui
derrière ses airs un peu propres et se
verrait bien la tête de touche pas
mangini dans six mois a alors les deux
côte à côte
tu as beau petit beau combat de coqs un
pur régal j'ai essayé de les départager
en toute objectivité
un peu comme si à l'époque
quatre mandats
kalilou
ce soit le tiers de ma carrière et
pétrole
je n'ai pas donné mon coeur
possible mais maxime a un avantage sur
mathieu un atout imparable pour
continuer à faire le kéké
contrairement aux vieux jeunes il a
gagné un prime maxime queyret essart et
vieux il l'a toujours pas digéré donc la
finale de ce combat va se jouer là
dessus c'est la mort subite
julie ricci total devait naître à nimani
qui vend tellement hip hop dub inc
achètent des biberons sans son mari sa
classe non l'insolent des débutants
comme ces quinze mois selon à aider les
cantons prime j'ai pas entendu la date a
dit quoi nous laver ça va aller faire
envier le premier en 1 18 non non non
vraiment ça y est on a déterminé la
thématique je crois et c'est la
thématique qui ont des parts